[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour la première fois dans
cette émission je reçois en tête à tête
un politique le premier j'espère d'une
longue série où on laissera s'exprimer
au calme leur vision du monde leur
intelligence et même pourquoi pas leur
complexité
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir vous êtes le
député des bouches du rhône président du
groupe
la france est soumise à l'assemblée
nationale est l'auteur de l'ère du
peuple qui est désormais en poche chez
plurielles merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation vous essuyer les plâtres pour
ainsi dire oui j'ai été séduit et je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité parce
que vous m'avez proposé de débattre de
ce sujet qu'il ne m'a été impossible
jusque là de mettre sur la chaîne
publique
la mère l'espace et l'espace numérique
en tant que nouveaux territoires et
nouvelles frontières
j'en suis désolé mais je n'y suis pas
arrivé hélas pour la première fois
l'occasion m'est donnée d'en parler de
montrer qu'à l'importance ces questions
ont pour notre quotidien sans qu'on le
sache toujours mais je tiens bien
apprécié nous parlons des espaces de
territoire de nouvelles frontières au
sens de territoire c'est pas les
nouvelles frontières du savoir ou non
s'agit du territoire des maires du
territoire si j'ose dire avec des
grosses guillemets de l'espace infini et
du territoire de la toile numérique qui
couvre le monde avec ses portes d'entrée
ses portes de sortie ces pentes ses
côtes
ces sommets et sa guerre ces lois et
tout ce qui s'y déroule comme si c'était
un de ces territoires qu'on a connu
jusqu'à présent qui sont notre plancher
des vaches
il ya d'autres territoires que au
préalable j'aimerais aborder avec vous
peut-être plus de politique jean-luc
mélenchon
à la dernière présidentielle vous avez
été 4e mais ça s'est joué dans un
mouchoir de poche
vous étiez à moins de deux points de
marine le pen 600 mille voix c'est très
très peu 600 mille voix vous étiez même
le premier chez les jeunes de moins de
35 ans premier devant emmanuel macron
devant et marine le pen devant françois
fillon est ce que un moment vous êtes
dit que vous avez failli gagner c'était
vraiment un cheveu est ce que vous vous
dites encore aujourd'hui je peux gagner
alors à l'époque oui je me suis dit que
je pouvais gagner quoi que j'ai
réellement le nez dans le guidon que
d'une campagne électorale voyez vous on
n'a pas trop le temps de faire de
l'introspection dans ces circonstances
je me suis dit que j'avais une chance
raisonnable de gagner à la fois du fait
de la violence de la charge médiatique
qui se faisait contre moi qui est est
tellement caricaturale que le comprenez
bien qu'il y avait le feu à la maison un
canton est interviewé sur le plateau de
tf1 la dernière semaine et qu'on vous
demande comme première question est il
vrai que vous vouliez quitté l'union
européenne
pour adhérer à l'alliance bolivarienne
vous vous demandez où vous êtes et vous
vous dites qu'il se passe quelque chose
on m'avait aussi mis à la une du journal
les échos comme étant un facteur de
renchérissement des assurances et des
emprunts alors je me suis dit il ya ça
et puis les instituts de sondage aussi
m'avait dit monsieur mélenchon attendait
la dernière minute parce que vous êtes
dans un mouchoir de poche les quatre
alors les raisons qui ont conduit à
cette situation
je crois qu'elles sont toujours là sinon
qu elles se sont aggravées depuis
si bien que je ne serai pas répondre à
votre deuxième question je ne sais pas
de quelle manière va se traduire l'état
d'esprit public en france après une
éradication des organisations politiques
traditionnels en 2017
puisque ça s'est terminé avec trois
opposants absolue à tous qui est
monsieur macro aidé à me le pen et moi
chacun dans dans notre genre et parce
qu'ensuite il ya eu le mouvement des
gilet jaune qu'a disloqué ce qui restait
de champ politique et sociale et puis
surtout actuellement
l'éruption du salariat organisé de notre
pays dans la lutte pour le maintien du
système de retraite hérité de la
libération
donc
comment avec la france à la sortie de
tout ça là je cite des événements en
général mais il faudrait être capable de
se rendre compte que dans le détail la
france n'est plus la même après une
présidence qui a manifesté autant mépris
pour le peuple
je crois qu'il en est même pas conscient
il fait partie de le président macron de
ces catégories sociales qui ont fait
sécession d'avec la masse du peuple
français
ces gens qui vivent entre eux qu'ils ne
se rendent pas compte de ce qu'il peut y
avoir de deux blessant à dire dans les
gares
il ya ceux qui ont réussi leur vie et
ceux qui ne sont rien j'avais même la
droite de nous a parlé comme ça quand il
dit j'en ai marre qu'on dise la
pénibilité du travail comme si le
travail était pénible bon bien sûr le
mien de travail est moins pénible que
celui d'un égoutier mais en attendant
les boutiques son travail heureusement
qu il le fait parce que sinon ni vous ni
moi ne serait ici en train de de parler
tranquillement donc ça a été ressentie
comme autant de gifles
si bien que la france et labouré par les
conséquences de ce mépris social et nous
ne savons pas comment des gens vous
réagir à ça vous ne savez pas je ne le
sais pas ce que ce que l'on observe
depuis les élections de 2017 c'est que
les partisans du président de la
république ont tout fait pour assimiler
la france insoumise avec le
rassemblement national
comme si en fait il y avait une grande
bataille une unique bataille entre
progressistes d'un côté populiste de
l'autre et que la variable de gauche
avaient été réduites à néant
est-ce que vous avez l'impression je
suis sûr que oui mais vous allez me dire
en quoi la gauche a encore est encore
capable de se distinguer aujourd'hui
dans ses propositions dans sa vision du
monde
bien sûr mais commençons par le début
c'est une ruse politique qui a permis
l'élection du président macron les gens
pas voté pour lui ils ont voté contre
madame le pen en tout cas un nombre
considérable a été convaincu que c'était
ça qu'il fallait faire bon comme c'est
une martingale électorale ça marche
c'est venir à qui avait besoin de faire
ça marche tout seul c'est pourquoi
j'avais été conduits à dire que madame
le pen est en quelque sorte l'assurance
vie du système parce que une table une
chaise
macron contre elle c'est l'autre qui
gagne bon mais après il essaye de
reproduire ça dans des conditions qui
sont désastreuses parce que
se rendent pas compte que il d'abord les
gens ne le croient pas ils ont cru un
temps mais dire que les insoumis et le
rassemblement national c'est la même
chose
tout le monde sait que c'est pas vrai
d'ailleurs les insoumis le savent
évidemment mais aussi les membres du
rassemblement national parce que nous
nous affrontons à peu près partout et
sur à peu près tout et puis les gens qui
sont des faut pas prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles c'est toujours l'erreur de
la macro ni prennent les gens pour des
crétins des demeurés qui sont incapables
de d'analysé alors après votre question
sur la gauche si elle est un peu plus
compliqué parce que il ya le mot et puis
la réalité
le mot a été dégradée d'une manière
incroyable par des gens comme monsieur
hollande et la loi elle comme riz et et
toute cette époque si vous voulez de
mensonges de mystification qui fait que
les gens qui appartenait à cette école à
cette tradition sans sont écartés les
ans pour s'abstenir
les autres rageur pour faire autre chose
notamment pour voter avec moi et puis
d'autres enfin totalement perdu on finit
par s'éparpiller sur la scène politique
alors il faut bien distinguer il faut
comprendre qu est-ce qui est l'auteur du
mot gauche et de sa réalité politique
moi j'ai passé toute ma vie à gauge
ailleurs compte tenu de mon âge j'ai
traversé un monde dans lequel la gauche
était non pas à résiduelles mais
centrale après après la libération
les générations qui ont suivi nous avons
vécu dans l'ombre de choc de cet
événement considérable de la défaite du
nazisme mais le mot gauche
il est né en france à un moment bien
précis de l'histoire
il s'agit de savoir si le roi a un droit
de veto ou pas
comprenez bien l'idée si le roi a un
droit de veto ça veut dire qu'il ya une
limite le droit de veto ça veut dire il
peut s'opposer à tout voir on veut lui
proposer une loi qui dit laver touche
pas d'accord ça veut dire qu'il ya une
personne a le même pouvoir que le peuple
tout entier
représenté par ses députés donc la
question du droit de veto a mis en en
oeuvre à ressorts politiques qui ne
s'est jamais détendu depuis il y avait
ceux qui disaient ah ben oui le roi
quand même c'est leur audace et dieu qui
donc on doit admettre l'idée alors
aujourd'hui saabas et le marché qu'est
ce que vous voulez monsieur mélenchon
peut pas faire autrement vu devez bien
vous rendre compte
c'est et puis de l'autre côté ceux qui
disent il n'y a rien au dessus de la
souveraineté populaire le peuple peut
commettre des erreurs mais on ne connaît
rien de mieux que de lui donner le
pouvoir est d'admettre que rien ne
s'impose à lui
le pari des républicains et des
vainqueurs de la grande révolution 89
c'était que plus le niveau d'éducation
montrait s'élèverait plus l'éducation se
répandrait et plus la cause républicaine
l'emporterait pas tout à fait tort c'est
quand même ce qui s'est passé en général
mais nous avons quand même eu des
répétitions d'épisodes autoritaires
soient que des gens aient voulu dominer
la société par l'autorité puis de temps
à autre en évoquant le pouvoir divin
soit que cet été des gens comme le
général boulanger à une époque où
d'autres personnes ou en ce moment
monsieur macron qui pensent qu'il est la
quintessence de l'intelligence et que
tous les autres sont de 2 des
personnalités dérisoire qui n'ont pas de
bon sens quand vous allez à l'assemblée
nationale
autrefois ont protesté parce qu'avec des
professeurs disent et au bras gauche 1
et maintenant nous voyons que des drh et
sont des gens qui ont une vision
complètement techno la hache directeur
des ressources du pays par dont les
directeurs de ressources humaines et des
gens de cette nature qui constitue le
gros de la troupe de la république en
marche alors ils ont aussi leur leurs
réflexes qui est essentiellement
technocratique il pense qu'il y a une
raison supérieure qui permet de dégager
une solution et une seule le concept
même de démocratie c'est à dire du fait
pour se disputer que même quand on
tranche c'est pas vraiment sûr que
quelqu'un ait raison ça leur échappe
complètement complètement
combien de fois ils débarquent war vous
parlez encore ben oui ça s'appelle
parlement on parle on essaye de se
convaincre et d'incarner des points de
vue ils sont culturellement éloigné de
l'idée de démocratie parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas la substance il se donne
par d'autres internautes ont bien réussi
la variable de gauche de cette
intolérance là qu'est la dictature du
prolétariat
on a beau mettre à la place du roi mais
prolétariat et il a toujours réseau
russie
vous avez raison tout ce qui dans
l'histoire prétend incarner une
transcendance qui s'imposerait quelque
chose qui serait supérieur et donc un
clergé en particulier connaîtrait les
mécanismes finit toujours mal parce que
ça ne peut pas tenir parce que
l'élévation de l'éducation dans tous les
pays notamment en urss qui avait fait
rebond absolument spectaculaire en
passant d'un d'un sous-développement
médiévale à la première puissance
technique du mont il rappelle que le
premier spoutnik le premier homme dans
l'espace temps russe la russie était une
super puissance technologique seconde a
été possible que par l'éducation alors
il est évident qu'à partir de là le
parti unique et la police politique ça
ne pouvait pas suffire
et ça pouvait pas suffire à faire
fonctionner la société les bases du
consentement à l'autorité était sapé par
l'inexistence de la possibilité de se
contredire et je crois que c'est vrai
comme ça tout le temps pour nous autres
les français c'est une vieille histoire
elle commence en 14 187 avec le livre de
pic de la mirandole c'est le début de
l'humanisme de la dignité de l'homme est
libre
voilà l'être humain epiméthée abbey dawn
est née talent à tous les animaux sauf à
l'être humain l'avait oubliée alors au
dernier moment qu'est ce qu'on fait de
lui promettait arrive et lui donne le
feu et l'être humain est un être qui
entièrement responsable de sa
construction
si on avait le temps et si on faisait
des missions sur le thème je vous
montrerai pourquoi même biologiquement
nous sommes le résultat d'une auto
construction culturelle
par conséquent tous les régimes qui nie
la démocratie sont condamnés à terme
sais pas combien de temps ça prend mais
c'est condamner par deux facteurs
l'éducation est le nombre des personnes
plus les gens sont nombreux et nous
sommes très nombreux sur cette planète
plus les liens s'intensifie et plus ça
va contre l'intuition un plus il ya des
masses plus il ya des individus parce
que quand vous êtes dans une masse vous
devenez dépendant de chêne
d'interdépendance extrêmement longue des
cas regardez vous même de combien de
mots de passe et d'identifiants vous
dépendez de combien de guichet pour vous
rendre compte que indépendamment de vos
très personnel et de notre culture vous
êtes un être tout à fait singulier y en
a pas deux comme vous ni comme moi ni
comme personne ici
dans ce studio voilà les deux facteurs
qui vont effondré tout le temps les
structures autoritaires il faut s'en
réjouir c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'appartiens à une nouvelle génération
de révolutionnaires
c'est ce qui mise tout sur la démocratie
et sur les assemblée constituante pour
que le peuple définisse lui-même les
droits qu'il se reconnaît qui donc
s'institue en tant qu'acteur politique
dans l'histoire ça c'est une
c'est une stratégie politique nouvelle
qui n est pour l'essentiel dans
l'amérique du sud dans les années de
rupture avec le néolibéralisme et que
nous avec la théorie de l'ère du peuple
et de la révolution citoyenne ils ont
soumis on a développé et porter jusqu'à
son terme mais vous l'avez dit s'en est
fallu de peu qu'on y arrive
tranquillement avec des bulletins de
vote
néanmoins jean luc mélenchon certains
disent aujourd'hui que même si on est
toujours dans une démocratie
représentative et qu'on peut choisir son
prochain président de la république lui
même seraient condamnées de toutes
façons à faire la même politique et que
demi que ses prédécesseurs parce qu'en
étant dans la zone euro on a abandonné
la possibilité d'avoir une politique
économique autonome et que au fond si
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron hier
françois hollande ou avant nicolas
sarkozy ont fait semble-t-il la même
politique en tout cas c'est l'impression
quand nous les français à base de
réduction des services publics et de
flexibilisation du marché du travail
c'est tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
pas tellement choix ils ont le choix sur
va-t-on hausser les impôts ou pas vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur sept vivaient
sur le sur le diagnostic je suis
d'accord avec vous ils font la même
politique parce qu'il se soumette à la
même politique
il considère que les traités européens
sont indépassables que madame merkel
incarne la raison de son différend
négocier des traités
oui mais ils ne l'ont pas fait ils ne
l'ont pas fait ils ne sont pas parler de
l'histoire non ils ne l'ont pas fait du
tout ils n'ont même pas essayé
vous n'avez pas trace dans l'histoire
d'un seul instant où un de ces trois
présidents que vous venez de nous mais
ai dit écoutez ça peut plus aller comme
ça bon vous voyez bien que y'a rien qui
marche
maintenant il serait fondé à dire ben
écoute et non seulement ça marche pas
mais quand on demande aux gens ce qu'ils
en pensent qu'ils s'en vont voir le
break site
donc ils se sont soumis mais il faut
quand même aussi dire pourquoi c'est
parce qu'ils représentent les classes
sociales
restait à ce mode de fonctionnement
qu'est ce que c'est traité institue une
donnée qui ne peut pas bouger donc qui
garantit la valeur de la rente
c'est ça que sa garantie et c'est le
coeur des lectorats de madame merkel
voir et de l'autre côté une politique de
réduction de la surface de l'état social
et du service public de manière à
confier au marché et donc à
l'accumulation le moyen de payer ses
rentes par capitalisation
monsieur taddei ces choses sont d'une
simplicité absolue alors après
intervient un facteur dans l'histoire
auquel vous devriez être sensible après
la question vous est posée il ya un
instant ce facteur c'est le facteur
humain qu'est ce que les gens dans leur
antre parce que l'histoire ne s'est pas
arrêtée avec les traités européens
le dieu n'est pas descendu sur terre
pour nous dire eh ben voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut faire
je le dis par matière de plaisanterie
mais c'est un épisode dans l'histoire ça
passera on passera à autre chose le
moment où il y aura des autorités
politiques capables de dire non moi je
me sens capable de ça je les dis à
d'autres qui ne sont pas sentis capables
comme alexis tsipras ce je me sens
capable de le faire pourquoi pas parce
que nous sommes une nation puissante et
puis parce que je n'ai aucun intérêt aux
intérêts qui sont servis par ses traités
sais c'est pas nous c'est pas ma classe
sociale c'est pas je je je je n'y a
aucune attache par contre pour moi c'est
très très très très important de
développer l'investissement au public de
passer à la planification écologique de
répartir la richesse pour que l'on cesse
avec lundi n'y peuvent voter que l'on
constate en allemagne ou en france dont
monsieur taddei faut admettre que
l'histoire est faite par les êtres
humains et qu'il y en a qui n'ont rien
dans le ventre et d'autres si ou bien il
y en a qui sont attachés à une cause et
et d'autres à d'autres ce que je leur
reproche et de mentir
monsieur hollande n'a jamais eu
l'intention de combattre la finance ni
de renégocier les traités
il a pourtant dit le contraire mais il
n'a dit formellement vous avez raison il
a rien fait monsieur sarkozy a fait les
gros yeux à madame merkel mais enfin ils
avaient en commun d'être tous les deux
de la même politique et de la même
droite
quant à monsieur macron il a fait toutes
les sottises possible l'une derrière
l'autre qui auront suffit à faire
comprendre à nos partenaires on va
mettre des guillemets qui n'était pas
sérieux parce que il acceptait toutes
sortes de choses qui sont inacceptables
accepter en cours de route et il a cédé
devant madame merkel merkel c'est une
femme extrêmement pragmatique elle
applique sa politique toi celle qui
convient à la majorité qui est la sienne
politique en allemagne à la majorité
socialo des grosses 30
et pour ça faut qu'il y ait de
l'accumulation aidé beaucoup de
dividendes donc ces gens préfèrent voir
les routes déglingué les ponts
s'effondrer n'avoir aucun service public
mais du moment que sa garantie
les revenus de ce petit catégories
sociales de rentiers gris et amenèrent
qui sont là alors c'est un pays où il ya
de moins en moins d'enfants où il ya
moins d'un an - de joie de vivre où il
ya de plus en plus de pauvres mais ils
sont contents sur leur tas d'argent ce
sont des comportements névrotique parce
que si vous regardez un état comme la
bavière où d'autres l'état dans lequel
sont les infrastructures publiques de ce
pays
l'argent qui savoure refuse de le
dépenser ils refusent ils vous le disent
ils le disent dans les interviews diane
en nombre et puis de toute façon c'est
pas efficace parce qu'il faut du temps
pour que s'appliquent enfin ces gens
sont incroyables
alors voilà c'est tentant de l'histoire
il faudra tourner la page on s'est tous
ceux qui ne le savent pas
sont en train de l'apprendre d'y voir
quelque chose qui va vous paraître
éloigné en incendies en australie
personne ne s'est arrêté mais pourquoi
pourquoi là parce qu'il y avait de l'eau
mon l'a vendu au fonds de pension il y
avait des pompiers m'ont à diminuer leur
nombre parce qu'il faut pas que l'état
soit à porter alors c'est pas le capital
qu'à allumer le feu abassi parce que la
température monte du fait du
productivisme bon par conséquent les
gens vous avez compris si vous voulez
cette politique voilà ce que ça donne
et ça donnera jamais rien d'autre de
même moi qui suis élu de marseille je
peux vous dire il tombe de l'eau commune
ans et j'avais tomber pourquoi parce que
la méditerranée se réchauffe plus vite
que les autres maires donc évaporation
précipitations sur une nature
imperméabilisées par les constructions
et par une nature physics et pas les
causes qui aura le grand sud est qui a
pas à la verdure la capacité pour la
terre d'éponger donc la première fois
les égouts explose tous détruits et tout
le monde court pour réparer la deuxième
fois on fait ce qu'on peut on nettoie ce
qu'on peut puis la troisième fois chacun
se débrouille et on vous dit
responsabiliser vous achetez vous une
citerne
achetez vous un groupe électrogène c'est
à dire qu'est ce que vous venez de nous
saouler à vouloir à tout prix
l'électricité puisse être pas capables
de faire des économies prenez vous
à vous alors si vous êtes la pauvre
personne qui n'en a pas les moyens et
bien cette société vous dit tu peux
crever jean luc mélenchon jusqu'où vous
remettez en cause du capitalisme est ce
que vous pensez que il faut en finir
avec le capitalisme
il ne nous a rien apporté ou ou au
contraire il faut le tempérer comme on a
su le tempérer à d'autres époques
pourrait aussi bien franklin roosevelt
le général de gaulle ont pleuré tout le
monde a oublié que la planification en
france c'est une invention du général de
gaulle
bon le capitalisme ça a été un moment de
l'histoire il a changé de forme
on aurait tort d'en parler comme d'un
sujet politique constant le capitalisme
de notre époque n'a rien à voir avec le
capitalisme
on va mettre des grosses guillemets
productif du 19e et du 20e siècle
l'essentiel du capitalisme notre temps
est concentré dans la sphère financière
où il réalise des taux de profit que
vous n'aurez jamais aucune chance de
réaliser dans la production réelle
donc c'est ce capitalisme là qu'il faut
abattre pour commencer il ya aussi celui
qu'on voit là il sauf qu'il ya cette
image derrière vous et derrière moi avec
ses fameux containers qui sont les
anglais vous impressionne les emblèmes
de la mondialisation c'est vous vous
rendez compte
d'abord la mondialisation c'est pas le
bon mot c'est les anglais caught bon
pour une fois globale à glace mais est
ce que vous vous rendez compte que si
énorme que soit cette image est bien les
échanges réels c'est à dire ça à la c4
mille fois moins que les échanges
financiers c'est à dire que en
permanence ses chants l'unmas de titres
qui ne représentent rien et qui
surplombe toutes les productions y
compris ce que vous voyez derrière vous
y compris le statut des marins qui sont
sur ce bateau qui doit coûter le moins
possible pour que et cetera et cetera et
cetera les mêmes logiques par conséquent
ne vous laissez pas impressionner ce
n'est pas ce capitalisme là qui dirige
c'est le capitalisme financier ça ne
veut pas dire que cela soit vertueux non
parce que vous avez remarqué les
caractéristiques du capitalisme de notre
temps il ne satisfait pas les besoins
élémentaires des personnes il reste des
milliards de gens qui mangent pas comme
pas d'eau potable ou qui sont pauvres
mais il crée des besoins artificiels par
la publicité
il crée des besoins qui sont solvables
et il ne répond pas aux besoins qui ne
sont pas solvables comme se nourrir se
vêtir avoir de l'eau potable et le reste
si bien que sur la terre entière
r nous sommes entrés dans une ère
nouvelle caractérisée par une population
considérable
nous sommes 7 milliards d'êtres humains
et il faut savoir que l'humanité change
de fond en comble chaque fois qu'elle
double je suis né dans un monde il y
avait deux milliards d'êtres humains
nous sommes sept mille seront bientôt
aux il ya pas besoin d'être un des clans
politiques pour comprendre que la
prédation qui s'exerce sur la nature
quel que soit le système social est
augmenté du fait qu'on n'ait 11
milliards mais alors quand la prédation
a lieu dans le cadre du capitalisme
notre époque c'est à dire de production
moyens extra de besoins extravagant et
bien il est clair que c'est un saccage
c'est plus que élise les auteurs du
désastre sont eux mêmes conscients du
désastre mais n'en peuvent mais que
peuvent-ils faire sinon continuez comme
il faisait si bien qu' on est à un
tournant de la civilisation humaine vous
savez je préfèrerais que ça se passe
bien mais il est possible si que ça se
passe mal peut-être bon que les pluies
qui tombent sur le grand sud est à force
de tout démolir
il va y avoir un moment quelque chose
s'écroule et se passe dans plusieurs
endroits du monde
nous pouvons considérer comme un
écroulement ce qui se passe en australie
les gens sont là les braves à la
regarder le feu quoi faire 1
alors le capitalisme est autant
condamner par lui même que par l'idée
qu'on s'en fait
pour ma part je suis assez pragmatique
j'utilise ce qui me sert pour la
politique que je veux faire alors je
suis un peu désolé j'en profite je vais
encore essayer ici de dire que le
capitalisme productif français me
désespère désole je suis même chagriné
d'une certaine façon parce que je
croyais que les patrons français les
patrons qui dirigent des usines
entreprises étaient des gens plus on l'a
vu dans le passé plus audacieux plus
créatifs et là le capital financier se
lance dans une attaque sur les retraites
il se gorge en ce moment parce que quand
il ya la grève
il s'en fout tant les âges et aux
continuent à tourner les prêts continue
à tourner le capital financier souffre
pas une demi minute
tous les patrons productif par contre
c'est pas pareil les marchandises qui ne
sont pas produites qui ne sont pas
transportés qui n'arrivent pas à sentir
des ports ils sont en train ils cotisent
l'aï cotisent pour les financiers les
mêmes qui les étrangle parce que quand
un patron productif fait des bonnes
affaires très vite rappelé ical bo c'est
à dire une société de fonds
this man qui vient qui donne la grosse
pièce 1 et puis qui prend tout et qui
saccagent et qui vident de sa substance
je suis chagrin de voir comment ça se
fait qu'il n'y a pas eu de capitalistes
français pour racheter le chantier naval
de saint nazaire alors que les carnets
de commandes sont remplis
comment ça se fait qu'il ya pas de
capitalistes français pour racheter
latécoère et les équipementiers de
latécoère qui produisent un système qui
permet de voir la nuit
c'est énorme c'est américains qui vont
acheter ça donc je les trouve finalement
assez parasitaire comment dire un peu
inutile alors bon voilà comme disait un
syndicaliste allemand on trouve des
ouvriers qui coûte moins cher on
pourrait trouver des patrons qui coûte
moins cher parce que cela coûte très
cher et c'est déraisonnable
alors vous me direz des patrons il ya
des petits des moyens tout ça c'est pas
la même chose entre les patrons du cac
40 et celui de l'entreprise de plomberie
maçonnerie de votre quartier c'est pas
la même chose mais il faudrait que les
petits arrête de se prendre pour des
gros parce qu'il verrait new et leurs
intérêts ont fait une pause jean luc
mélenchon se retrouve dans un instant
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je veux reprendre sa monnaie ne
résout pas tous les toutous les
problèmes bien sûr qu'il faut changer
les hommes qui dirigent parce que sinon
vous ne résoudrait rien en sortant de
l'euro on veut en fait forcé la marge du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
regretteront envie de voir cette marche
de transformation du pays est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
oui
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés il ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation le citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
une émission spéciale avec jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui la première d'une
série avec des dirigeants politiques
jean luc mélenchon est ce que la france
est bien encore une grande puissance
vous y avez fait allusion dans la
première parmi notre conversation
à partir du moment où elles d'appui plus
avoir de politique économique autonome
est elle encore indépendante
économiquement militairement
politiquement même est ce que
véritablement c'est une grande puissance
face à aux états unis et la chine à
l'albanie où est la russie bon tout
dépend ce qu'on vise par la puissance ce
qui est certain c'est que la france
n'est plus un état indépendant
beaucoup de ces décisions se prennent
dans le secret de la commission
européenne et s'impose à notre peuple
par exemple la demande de supprimer les
systèmes de retraites que nous avons
mais auparavant c'était la vente des
barrages électriques c'est la
suppression des services publics c'est
l'europe telle qu'elle est l'union
européenne est une machine à détruire
tout ce qui l'entourent après nous
sommes complètement dépendant des états
unis d'amérique sur le plan militaire
parce que deux présidents nous on
liquider militairement c'est françois
hollande qui a accepté qu'on installe
des batteries de missiles antimissiles
en pologne ce qui voulait dire que du
jour au lendemain la dissuasion
française d'un peu de sens et puis le
président hollande aussi qui a accepté
comme ils disent là l'inter opérationn
habilité ça veut dire parler tour glem
est installé des logiciels que
contrôlent les nord-américains jusque
dans le ministère de la défense c'est à
dire et sur certains de nos missiles et
même pour les satellites que nous tirons
tout le système qui va remplacer les gps
américain les américains ont obtenu
qu'on mette les satellites sur une autre
orbite que le gps de manière à ce que
s'ils veulent nous couper ils se coupent
eux mêmes et deuxièmement ils ont obtenu
d'être embarqué pour l'observation
militaire donc voilà nous ne sommes plus
indépendant mon projet est de nous
rendre de nouveaux indépendants est ce
qu on a des outils bien évidemment
regarder nous allons parler maintenant
de la mer c'est l'espace le plus vaste
sur la planète
il contient des richesses tout à fait
extraordinaire 71 % du territoire de la
planète
2 t de l'eau c'est la mer on en sait
moins sur le fond de la mer que sur la
planète mars et nous les français nous
sommes le deuxième territoire du monde
mais pour que l'état fasse son boulot
nous sommes ridicules je ne dis même pas
inexistant je vais jusqu'à ridicule la
totalité du territoire marin des
français est contrôlé par l'équivalent
de ce qu'il faudrait pour contrôler tout
le territoire terrestre de l'hexagone
comme si sur tout l'hexagone y avait
deux voitures de police
et bien c'est l'équivalent nous avons
deux bateaux si j'ose dire pour
contrôler tout ce territoire c'est que
nous donnons aucun des moyens du
contrôle de la puissance de
l'investissement et c'est lamentable
parce que les chercheurs français les
océanographes joue un rôle magique sur
le plan mondial
ça c'est un exemple deuxième exemple
l'espace l'espace nous sommes personne
ne le sait le deuxième peuples du monde
pour la cotisation individuelle à un
budget de l'espace et nous les français
donc mais de la poche
on est super bon les fusées qui sont
françaises pour pour la 90% de là ce
sont les français les appareils
embarqués est ce que vous savez que la
mission sur mars
le petit le truc là qui roule là le
laboratoire est français la caméra est
française bon alors les pneus sont
américains et ça a été pire avec une
fusée américaine mais je veux dire que
dans cet attelage là nous sommes la
partie quand même noble 1 de la faire et
puis rappelez vous la dernière mission
spectaculaire qui a été la sonde rosetta
sur l'astéroïde story alors c'était
terrifiant c'est une patate violet avec
une forme comme ça on a posé une petite
mouche l'a1 et elle a observé tout ce
qui se passait autour
nous sommes donc une super puissance
intellectuelle moi je mise tout
là-dessus et dans le domaine alors
l'appareil on en sait fait liquider
parce que les français ont admis des
programmes communs avec les allemands
qui ne respectent rien qui ne prennent
pas la fusée ariane pour premier
objectif c'est à dire que quand ils ont
des satellites attirer fonds suivant
leur humeur avec des américains ou avec
d'autres bons c'est totalement déloyale
nous avons accepté que les états unis on
parle de l'espace la promulguer des lois
absolument insupportable le traité de
1967 disait l'espace c'est la propriété
de l'humanité ça appartient à personne
vu d'interroger quelqu'un dans la rue
diarra ben oui les étoiles tout ça c'est
un tout le monde enfin en fait c'est à
personne parce que encore faudrait-il y
arriver les américains ont voté une loi
qui dit abandonnant le premier car ils
s'emparent de ce qu'il a et ça lui
appartient
alors cette loi peut vous faire sourire
mais au début j'ai cru à un gag mais
disent pas possible comment ils peuvent
bel 6 et ils s'organisent pour ça ils
ont des sociétés privées qui tiraient
des fusées sur différents astéroïde il
se prépare à ça mais on pourrait dire ah
bon ben ce sont des américains ont une
mentalité de cowboy bon toute la terre
entière est stupéfaite
où trouve-t-on quelqu'un pour trouvé ça
génial en europe et c'est le luxembourg
grandes puissances spatiales comme
chacun le sait qui a décidé de créer sur
son territoire le cadre juridique qui
permet aux sociétés qui veulent sans
pareil d'astéroïdes de le faire ils
peuvent déposer leurs titres luxembourg
y sont quand même membre de l'union
européenne cela qui a dit qu on accepter
une chose pareille ou comme disait
françois 1er quand on lui a appris le
partage de l'amérique entre l'espagne et
le portugal il a dit je voudrais voir le
testament d'adam qui dit que je suis
privé de cet héritage un bon ben moi
j'ai envie de dire pareil je voudrais
bien savoir qui a décidé un jour que les
nord-américains pouvait s'approprier
l'univers infini quant à la mère il est
évident pour nous les français qu'on a
intérêt à se bouger parce que toute
notre façade maritime sud c'est la
méditerranée la méditerranée c'est une
petite mer fermée un 13 km de passage
il y aura bientôt plus de plastique là
dedans queue de poisson
si nous sommes dans une situation de
désastre en cours en cours de route en
cours de réalisation dans la mer
méditerranée
évidemment les ressources naturelles
pour lesquelles les gens se battent sont
dans les pires endroits en phase ii de
gaza et à chypre où se battent les grecs
et les turcs
imaginez vous monsieur taddei que ces
gens qui veulent faire des trous partout
viennent à se rater ce qui est arrivé à
d'autres comme dans le golfe du mexique
imaginez-vous qui sera on trouve ça
marche pas ça commence à thiès qui va
les braults boucher le trou qui vous
sont les outils nous les français nous
avons fait
des sous marins nous avons eu les
premiers sous-marins qui descendent d'un
des très grandes profondeurs avec une
intervention humaine n'y a pas le début
du commencement d'un plan pour la
méditerranée tout au contraire on avait
un bon plan et on pouvait s'entendre
avec les pays riverains les allemands
sont sûrs de gala comment ça nous
intéresse tous et vous avez ce résultat
grotesque que les normes de pollution
pour les navires en méditerranée sont
beaucoup plus laxiste que elles ne le
sont en mer baltique où ce sont les
allemands qui sont occupés de faire
appliquer des règles si bien que la
grande puissance que nous sommes est
bafouée et défier et elle ne s'est pas
réagir elle ne sait pas prendre d'où la
question est ce qu'on nous sommes encore
une grande puissance
oui vous avez raison de vous poser la
question mais le problème n'est pas tant
d'être une grande puissance
le problème est d'être une puissance
utile bon une puissance utile il faut
pas se tromper de cheval si vous passez
votre temps à courir derrière les
américains et à passer par toutes leurs
lubies et sous stratégie par exemple a
désigné les russes comme des adversaires
alors que maintenant enfin même le
président de la république reconnaît que
les rues sont des partenaires vous vous
trompez de cheval parce que l'intérêt
fondamental de la france et de
s'entendre avec les russes alors on me
dit oui mais leur régime ne nous
convient pas ben c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant sous le régime soviétique
c'est le général de gaulle qui a fait un
accord avec pareil pour la chine
nous sommes le premier pays à avoir
reconnu la république populaire de chine
le 1er et pendant un temps les seuls et
alors donc la france pacte avec des
nations avec des peuples donc il ne faut
pas se tromper de cheval nous n'avons
rien à faire dans derrière la locomotive
américaine qui nous pillent nos
capacités intellectuelles et productive
qui nous mène comme ça à la trique vous
savez le dandé dans des impasses parce
que voyez le l'embargo qui a été mis sur
certains produits russes les seuls à qui
ça profite s et les russes parce qu'ils
ont remplacé les légumes et les fruits
que les européens notamment les français
produisent s est même qui les produisent
mais ça n'a jamais empêché un seul jour
les compagnies nord-américaines de
continuer à exporter chez les russes qui
rigole parce qu'ils savent très bien que
y'a pas station spatiale internationale
sans leurs fusées pour y amener du monde
parce qu'ils savent très bien que tout
ça n'a aucun sens cette agressivité qui
a développé contrôlant maintenant ça
s'est calmé
on est en train de s'en prendre aux
chinois ce qui est sans issue de même la
flotte doit pas se tromper
elle doit coopérer de manière non
alignés et je suis le porte parole si
j'ose dire de cet indépendantiste
français de ce non alignement
ça veut dire qu'on fait la politique de
personnel et c'est encore possible alors
même que vous le disiez militairement
on a besoin des américains pour
quasiment tous pour quoi faire
je sais pas vous nuire aux russes et aux
chinois mais non mais pour la wii mais
c'est à ça que ça se résume le la
puissance nord-américaine coopèrent et
veut qu'au concours pair avec elle pour
mener ces guerres invraisemblable mené
dreyer en dépit du bon sens parce que
qu'on m'explique ce qu'on a fait pendant
presque maintenant je sais pas combien
d'années depuis 2001 que nous y sommes
donc ça va faire bientôt vingt ans c'est
quoi le résultat en afghanistan c'est
quel était le but d'ailleurs les gens se
rappelle même plus un
on nous avait dit ruia là pour libérer
les femmes vont très bien mais on a
confié la constitution à une assemblée
traditionnelle
on y ajouter vous le savez peut-être la
plus grosse bombe de l'histoire humaine
a été jeté sur l'afghanistan par les
nord américains ce une bonne
conventionnel mais la plus grosse que
jamais été fabriquée de l'histoire c'est
une puissance de feu équivalente à celle
d'hiroshima
personne ne sais ni pourquoi on a jeté
cette bombe ni quel résultat on en
attendait nickel résultat ça a donné
donc tout ça c'est l' empire fait la
guerre comme une espèce de deux
mécanismes économiques intérieurs sains
l'argent qu'ils mettent dans les guerres
reviennent chez eux ce sont leurs
productions industrielles
ce sont leurs ouvriers qui donc fondu
près achètent des maisons des voitures
etc etc
l'économie de guerre est au centre de la
puissance nord américaine tous les
autres pays s'épuiserait pourquoi
peuvent-ils faire ça parce qu'ils ont un
privilège unique au monde
ils peuvent imprimer autant de dollars
qui le veulent personne ne leur demande
de contrepartie font ce qu'ils veulent
et ça ça date du 15 août 1961 il faut
donc bien analysé la super puissance je
serais pas loin de reproduire la formule
de mao tsé toung ce qui n'est pas
habituel dans ma bouche
à mes yeux c'est un tigre de papier il
faut saisir chaque occasion pour nous
parce qu'on est petit on va pas non plus
raconté d'histoires on est petit mais
terriblement audacieux et on peut être
très allants comme on est petit faut
choisir choisir les occasions
de manifester notre puissance non on va
pas aller faire le bagage accompagné des
noirs américains en syrie ni en irak et
dans le chaos qui règne dans cette zone
les kurdes sont un allié centrale pour
nous pas les turcs et quand les turcs
nous tirent dessus
eh ben on réplique alors on m'a dit vous
voulez faire la guerre avec la turquie
m'a dit le le premier ministre jamais
proposé de faire la guerre avec la
turquie mais je dis que c'est pas les
turcs qui décide où les français ont le
droit d'être en syrie c'est pourtant ce
qu'ils ont fait et combien d'autres
exemples de cette nature que je pourrai
données qui montrent que la france a
manqué de souplesse d'agilité pour
saisir les occasions au bon de rappeler
quel rôle elle joue et quelle est sa
puissance
nous sommes pas un petit pays nous avons
des moyens extrêmement nombreux d'agir
d'intervenir de savoir bon nous voyons
depuis le ciel aussi bien que les
nord-américains je vous signale la
révolution d'internet et des nouvelles
technologies a impacté énormément nos
comportements jean luc mélenchon on a
cru en a beaucoup misé sur son aspect à
la fois libertaire et égalitaire tout à
coup tout le monde est devenu émetteurs
tout le monde avait pu bénéficier des
techniques de la statistique par exemple
il son gps ce qui était réservé à des
états et des entreprises tout à coup
tout le monde peut peut en percevoir les
bénéfices
néanmoins aujourd'hui on a l'impression
d'entrer dans l'ère de la surveillance
de masse et ça aussi c'est permis à la
fois par internet par les téléphones
portables dont nous sommes si friands et
que nous avons tous dans nos poches
est ce que vous en pensez et où l'homme
de gauche que vous êtes aujourd'hui
comment se situe-t-il par rapport à
cette révolution alors d'abord
commençons par constater quelque chose
qui va peut-être choquer l'intuition la
toile c'est pas pour rien qu'on
l'appelle comme ça
l'univers numérique est un territoire
exactement comme avec nos vallées nos
plaines et reste donc et la mer et
l'espace
voilà donc il faut déjà y entrer donc il
ya les conditions d'entrée il ya ensuite
ce que vous y faites et quelles sont les
lois qui s'y appliquent et vous avez
toutes les questions qu'ils tiennent à
un territoire géographique alors déjà
pour y entrer il ya déjà des principes
toulon qu'il faut déformant les états
unis d'amérique ont
si dès que la neutralité du net c'était
fini ensuite il y a des lois qui
existent mais très curieusement elles
sont privatisées et vous avez par
exemple facebook qui fait une cour
suprême avec des philosophes et je sais
pas quoi qui décide d'être une cour
d'appel si un jour on ferme votre compte
alors vous faites appel il y aurait
cette cour qui dirait où vous oui vous
non bon alors que l'on sait très bien ça
à voir aussi avec la neutralité que par
exemple facebook à un algorithme qui est
censée rationaliser lutter contre la
cyber end on la lui s'appliquer aux
états unis d'amérique
la première conséquence c'est pas que la
violence ait diminué aux états unis
d'amérique et continue à être aussi
effarante
mais c'est que les sites pacifistes les
sites socialiste les sites de
contestation ont vu tout d'un coup leur
fréquentation s'effondrer bon donc
facebook a dans sa main par le fait même
que c'est lui qui a tracé les chemins
par lesquels vous passez pour échanger
nos amitiés la photo de nos gâteaux
d'anniversaire et que sais-je encore un
qui est cette espèce de de voisinage
beaucoup plus fort que le voisinage réel
et de lacan résulte-t-il que vous ne
pouvez plus vous en passer
vous ne pouvez plus vous en passer et
dès lors que vous ne pouvez plus vous en
passer c'est juste parce que vous
participez à la communauté humaine aisé
de les êtres humains sont des êtres
sociaux donc disais-je
il ya des lois maintenant il ya une
mener ils ont inventé une monnaie alors
donc une monnaie décider par eux aucun
état c'est un des privilèges centraux de
l'état de battre mené 1 et de la
garantir c'est fini ça se passe là
dessus c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui
décide et puis après vous avez les
conflits alors quel conflit non pensez
pas à vous avec vos engueulade avec les
gens qui font des commentaires sur vos
messages facebook ou twitter pensez aux
conflits des états-nations 50% des
piratages donc des destructions parce
que c'est ça dont on parle sur la toile
sont le fait des états nations se
portent des coups de vache absolue alors
on n'en parle pas beaucoup mais quand
même
par exemple on sait qui a piraté le
système d'un des pétroliers américains
et d'un coup 3000
mino ordinateur quick ont brûlé une
autre fois c'est un le centre qui
commande les drones en afghanistan qui a
été piraté alors on en est rendu au
point que à la fois par le côté bataille
pour le contrôle des territoires de
l'internet vous pouvez considérer que si
c'est vous qui mettez vous pétroliers
sur la mer c'est votre territoire
1 donc le contrôle de ce que vous êtes
en train de faire était absolument
équivalent à celui que il ya quelques
siècles que vous auriez eu à défendre
aux frontières et bien cette bataille
elle elle est en cours elle a lieu c'est
la ministre française qui a dit la
guerre du numérique et commençait alors
l ai commencé les etats-unis ont créé un
état major pour cette guerre et nous les
français on a créé un état major pour
l'espace mais en dedans il ya aussi
cette composante qui s'occupe du
numérique vous voyez que le territoire
du numérique est investie absolument de
toutes les fonctions humaines
traditionnelles et pauvres et il en est
autrement mais cette année il est un
être humain produit des choses qui est
le propre des êtres humains et de la
civilisation humaine
oui mais à une nuance près c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces technologies sont les
meilleurs qu'on ait jamais vu pour
ficher une population absolument jour
l'influencé pour la surveiller je
reviens toujours à ce terme de
surveillance on parle même de
capitalisme de surveillance est au fond
un logiciel de reconnaissance faciale en
chine ou en france il servira à la même
chose alors on peut se dire que la chine
est une dictature pas la france mais
sont des nuances que les technologies
ignore elle devra le même travail et que
ce soit vous sur luc mélenchon demain au
pouvoir ou emmanuel macron où marine le
pen ou se dit finalement ça servira de
la même manière est ce que vous vous
seriez différent des autres jeux je ne
veux pas faire croire ou dire écoutez
moi je suis bon et juste et généreux et
d autres non j'essaye de réfléchir en
disant qu'elle est l'intérêt du pays
comme on s'y prend si j'avais la
tentation moi de vouloir surveiller tout
le monde
supposons un je me dirais aussitôt mais
la machine avec laquelle je surveille
tout le monde n'importe qui rentre
dedans et contrôle tout mon peuple je
veux pas je veux pas qu on entre chez
moi et qu'on 2
in ce que je vais faire ou ce que les
français peuvent décider de faire dans
tel ou tel domaine
donc c'est par réflexe de lui en
alignement et d'indépendance que je ne
veux pas de ces procédés mais je ne suis
pas surpris qu'ils existent monsieur
tanner je vais vous dire beaucoup de
gens me font rire parce qu'ils ne se
rendent pas compte que tous les pouvoirs
ont toujours passé tout leur temps à
essayer de contrôler les gens alors les
pouvoirs d'ancien régime
c'était la religion et au village tout
le monde contrôler tout le monde et tous
les dimanches tout le monde allait à la
messe qui est une affaire de foi
évidemment et ça se respecte
mais c'était aussi l'occasion pendant
laquelle le curé expliquer ce qu'il
fallait faire ce qui était bien ce
n'était pas bien elle rêve et puis après
c'est la pub qui sait sa relance à tous
vos comportements monsieur taddeï sont
différents de ceux de vos pères et mères
et de vaud et de vos grands parents
parce que vous êtes un autre être humain
vous êtes façonné par des besoins des
désirs qui n'existait pas en vous avant
qu'on vous ait convaincu de choses comme
ça alors de temps à autre on envoie une
boursouflure risible 1
comme je sais plus qui l'a jeu tel grand
publiciste avait dit celui qui n'a pas
acheté telle montre à saint quentin a
raté sa vie je crois qu'il était d'une
terrible sincérité ils pensaient
réellement que réussir sa vie passe par
la possession certains aux gars étaient
à bord ce slogan mais je veux dire d'une
certaine manière il est il exprimé sans
pudeur sans se rendre compte qu'il était
un pudique une forme d'aliénation
absolument extraordinaire aux objets
donc partons de l'idée qu' il n'y a pas
de limite à la volonté de contrôler des
autres c'est comme ça et vous savez
c'est ancré dans les comportements
humains
demandez-vous j'ai lu des études de
sociologues d'anthropologues
nord-américaine ce qu'il faut aussi des
très belles choses dans les nord
américains le domaine des sciences et ce
type s'était intéressé à savoir pourquoi
il fait une enquête
il écoutait les gens parler dans les
bistrots et il était persuadé que les
gens s'échanger des informations
informative du genre à b demain je vais
faire si après demain il fera savoir
noté et ils découvrent avec stupeur que
les échanges informatif représentait à
peine le 15 % de ce qui se raconte et
tout le reste c'était des rumeurs et des
ragots
c'est à dire que chacun raconte alors ce
qu'ils pensent de tel autre de telle
autre et comme ce sont des darwin icd
scientifiques sont demandés pour
à quels avantages ça donnait il dit les
êtres humains qui sont bien renseignés
sur les autres adaptent leur
comportement
et comme ils l'adapt et bah ils ont de
meilleures chances de succès dans la vie
par conséquent ne vous étonnez pas après
ça quand pouvoir se disent qu'ils je
sais tout alors je contrôlerai tout
naturellement ils ne compteront pas tout
si vous voulez lire un bon bouquin de
science fiction sur le sujet je vous
recommande un bonheur insoutenable de
ira levin c'est donc un kid athlé qui
est fondée là dessus c'est à dire que
les machines vous contrôler et alors
suivant ce que vous êtes alors vous
taddei vous êtes journaliste vous aurez
droit à les acheter tant de kalpin d'en
prendre ailleurs ces données mais pas
plus et si moi qui suis pas journaliste
je décale pas bah non parce que c'est
pas mon métier les machines contrôle
tout et tout le monde et tout ce qu'ils
font évidemment à la fin je vous raconte
pas le livre parce que peut-être que
vous irez l'acheter tout ça se plantent
lamentablement parce que la fantaisie
humaine
le principe d'incertitude cette petite
part de folie qui est en nous qui
résultent de quelques principes auto
organisateurs voilà nous avons besoin de
manger dormir boire et d'aimer alors
notamment aimé le conduit à faire les
pires folies bon irrationnelle bon et
les autres de même ces quelques
principes font de nous des êtres
incontrôlable il y en a toujours un qui
fait pas comme les autres et quand il
fait pas comme les autres vous avez des
principes qui se mettent en oeuvre ça
s'appelle le désir mimétique
si vous le faites vous alors pourquoi je
ne ferai pas moi et vous avez qu à
regarder deux gosses en train de se
battre dans un bac à sable pour un saut
alors il n'y a rien à la main on peut
faire ce qu'elle veut elle peut venir
avec la jolie bicyclette les bonbons et
tout ce qu'on veut continuer à se battre
les êtres humains sont construits comme
ça n'ayez donc aucune confiance dans ce
qu'ils vous disent que il se limiteront
dans leur désir de vous contrôler si je
vous ai bien compris jean luc mélenchon
vous lui dites kangourou il est tout à
fait normal d'espérer sa population
contrôler le pouvoir parce que le
pouvoir a toujours essayé d'escalader sa
population qu'il y aura toujours des
guerres parce que on a toujours eu envie
de se battre parce qu'on veut
essentiellement ou désirent les mêmes
choses on convoite les mêmes choses donc
on est obligé de se battre et qu'il faut
pas croire donc ce qu'ils nous diront qu
il ne nous exprimerons pas et y compris
vous vous nous dites
en gros j'ai ce cadre est comme tout le
monde
et comme l'homme est irrationnel il
échappera non non il échappera si ça se
fait à des abondances roger commencer
par vous dire le contraire
tout dépend des principes qui motive
l'action si vous avez en vous la peur
des autres ce qui n'est pas mon cas
vous avez envie de les contrôler si vous
avez comme premier ressort le goût de la
liberté parce que vous ne voulez pas que
les autres puissent savoir ce que font
vos compatriotes
alors vous allez combattre les meilleurs
- parce que je crois moi c'est que ce
type de contrôle ne servent strictement
à rien c'est une dépense absolument
inutile sinon évidemment à quadriller
les populations pour ma part je m'y
opposerai c'est tout à fait clair et
mémé dans un cadre d'affrontements ou de
guerre larvée ou de guerre froide de
guerre contre le terrorisme
on sait ce que c'est de la garde contre
le terrorisme en attendant ce pour
protéger sa population à vouloir
l'espionné sans penser à mal
uniquement plus à wayaux pour je n'y
crois pas une seconde je n'y crois pas
une seconde je ne crois pas à la guerre
contre le terrorisme le terrorisme est
une abstraction il ya des actes
terroristes et pour lutter contre les
actes terroristes
le meilleur moyen c'est pas le contrôler
dans la rue tous le monde c'est d'avoir
des gens qui font le boulot sur le
terrain qui se mobilisent qui se
faufilent qui savent où aller
parce que nous avons eu dans le passé
des succès extraordinaires qui ont
rarement été dit à ses folies
d'espionnage général quand on voit qu'on
a installé dans paris des trucs pour
contrôler un quartier entier pardon mais
c'est à dire mais personne ne peut
prendre au sérieux une idée pareille 1
ce qui est à prendre au sérieux c'est
comme ont infiltré les moyens humains
j'ajoute pour la paix c'est exactement
de nature faut la vouloir la paix mais
ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui vole
la guerre les peuples n'ont pas du tout
le même rapport à la guerre prenons la
population des états unis d'amérique n'a
aucune idée de ce qu est une guerre bien
sûr elle a envoyé ces jeunes gens en
europe elle les envoyer au vietnam et
les envoyer dans toutes sortes de
conflits mais la population des états
unis n'a aucune idée de ce que c'est
d'être envahi comme nous l'avons été
nous à trois reprises par notre voisin
qui a saccagé entières du territoire
national ils n'ont aucune idée de ce que
ça a coûté à la russie d'être envahi par
les nazis un 20 millions morts ce sont
des choses qui marquent les peuples moi
je sais que le peuple français n'a pas
les moyens
de subir un choc de cette nature par
conséquent tout ce qui va faciliter la
paix repousser le risque de guerre et de
destruction intérieur je pense par
exemple aux catastrophes qui pourraient
surgir du fait du nucléaire est bon pour
le pays donc nous on doit être les
champions du monde de la proposition de
faire fonctionner les ennemis plutôt que
l'otan de s'accorder avec ceux qui dans
le moment non pas la première place
aujourd'hui la première place les états
unis d'amérique à la fois s'entendre
avec le deuxième et le troisième
et puis quand ne se lasseront premiers
vont s'entendre avec les autres il faut
toujours donner à la france
la possibilité d'être libre de ses
mouvements donc non alignés on est avec
personne sap avec tout le monde mais on
sait ce qu'on veut et ce qu'on ne veut
pas moi je ne veux pas de la guerre de
l'espace parce que nous la perdront
séance tenante
est ce que vous réalisez que les neuf
dixièmes des armements matériel que nous
utilisons ou des moyens de protection
que nous avons seize hommes une seconde
depuis l'espace vous comprenez on peut
depuis l'espace nous avons toutes sortes
d'activités humaines qui dépendent de
l'espace quatre pays savent détruire
depuis la terre un satellite dans
l'espace
les français aussi mais ils ne le disent
pas parce qu'ils sont hypocrites mais il
y en a quatre autres qui l'ont dit nous
savons le faire
heureusement nous aussi mais vous coupez
instantanément tous qui en dépend par
exemple votre gps galileo doit terminer
va essayer de vous retrouver maintenant
vous avez pu l'habitude de consulter les
panneaux et tout ça bon je vous donne
cet exemple mais plein d'autres combien
de nos armements ne fonctionne que parce
qu'ils sont interactifs bon c'est
beaucoup plus efficace de plonger la
france dans le noir de couper toutes ses
centrales nucléaires de leur
approvisionnement d'interrompre toute la
lumière sur notre sur notre pays que
d'aller détruire quatre pauvres chars
dans une plaine ou dans un désert c'est
beaucoup plus efficace militairement par
conséquent il est à peu près certain que
l'indépendance de la france repose à 90%
sur sa capacité d'intelligence qu'est ce
qu'on est capable de faire 1 et puis
aussi d'avoir moins confiance dans ceux
qui se prétendent nos amis parce qu'il
nous espionnent 1
et puis des fois on serait mieux
informés ça serait pas plus mal donc moi
je suis d'abord venu par le réalisme et
je sais que la paix n'est pas un état de
nature vous l'avez dit rien
instant il faut donc la construire faire
toujours attention il ya des gens qui
comprennent ça et je veux le dire ici il
ya des pays qui le comprennent mieux
d'autres c'est plus facile de discuter
avec un an russe de maintenir la paix
qu'avec un américain qui se croit une
espèce de mission d'évangélisation sur
la terre entière et qui déclenche des
guerres tous les trois ou quatre ans
comme nous assistons depuis tantôt 30
ans et qui les perd tout temps je ferai
remarquer aussi au passage je crois à la
puissance française en mer je crois à la
puissance française dans l'espace et je
ne crois capable est assez malin d'être
présents sur le territoire numérique
qu'on nous veut une puissance qui joue
un rôle nous on doit être utile si on
est utile à l'humanité on sera utile à
tout le monde et à tout d'abord il y en
a d'autres qui pensent que ces six sont
utiles à eux mêmes tout va bien c'est le
cas de monsieur trump même s'il se
trompe aussi durera pas peut-être que
c'est monsieur centers qui va gagner
l'élection aux états unis d'amérique
alors le sort du monde sera changé il
faut être optimiste
si vous n'avancez pas avec l'idée qu'on
peut améliorer la situation pourrait
vous cacher chez vous et pleurer parce
qu'elle est désespérante
mais il n'y a pas de situation dont on
puisse venir à bout par intelligence
merci jean luc mélenchon d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
moi